[Music]
I'm here my name is Wilson - originally
from Brazil live in two years Australia
and today I will talk some point some
tips and tricks things that can help you
to evolve your application like from
mono leaf application to a micro surfs
application but first of all let's talk
few things like I'm not that good with
jokes but trust me I'll do my best and
one thing that really interesting about
myself like I really like products so I
just want to call you guys to take a
small picture here and hey do something
crazy yeah I'm recording guys but yeah I
really love that things so you guys know
about me and know a little bit about
yourselves but let's talk about our
story once upon a time in the web
because every good story starts with
this phrase we had a few people who just
come together as a startup and they
create an application called my amaze
app larmes app came your idea of MVP
just to validate few few points about
the business and it works pretty well
but in a business way but in besides the
code
the initial version had some issues
first of all it was a mono life
application so after six months after
one year they realized that was an
application was hard to evolve hard to
maintain like add the feature or remove
a feature or evolve a feature was
something really painful for the team
and why because it was highly called
corporate code like it was presentation
layers and data based layers and
back-end layers everything was you guys
in the same place like we're talking
about an application that starts 10
years ago so that was something that in
that moment was not the main focus but
it started to be and because of mix of
layers they had some issues one of the
issues was related to the page load like
as you guys can see you have three HTTP
requests each one for each component but
you have some issues around like the
first ATP ATP call it was successfully
the second was just failed and the third
one it is still painting and the
application was not resilient for those
things so that was another point let's
talk about mobile website ten years ago
this was something that was interesting
for some companies and after that they
realized okay now we have two code bases
we have to duplicate a logic which is
insane
another point pretty much this company
had to care a lot about SEO and Google's
not benevolent if you're not following
the rules not only Google every surgeon
team if you're not following some
cereals SEO rules you just being
punished all right this is one of
auditions and as you guys can see we
have really really bad numbers like ten
performers and this was just example
using a tool called lighthouse and it's
enough so okay we know those points and
we know the code wedgie time when you
look is something like that you have
that feeling it really have that feeling
geez it's hard to maintain so what
happens every time there had that
feeling you try to avoid
that behavior okay if I just wanted to
add something of just add more code add
more code it's a natural behavior
it's not a good way to play this game
not at all so okay we came into this
idea why not now that we have the
business values totally validated let's
start improving because improvements are
cycle right so let's start with MVP our
main P now version 2 with few ideas in
your mind one of them is first do it
second gen do it right and then do it
better it's one of the phrase who came
long time ago of Russia agile manifest
it just another interpretation of the
same idea who is released early release
often do do it better do it always
better yeah let's talk about make it
better so we have few things that we
need to keep in mind right
our current application had to care
about SEO should be easy to maintain now
the company grow and it it's working
distributed across three three three
countries like Australia Brazil and
India for example we have really really
huge gaps on the stem zones should be
easy to maintain should be reusable
however every time they look those codes
you you can say ok I won't have this
feeling but in the end that's the first
idea who came in your mind just let it
be right because you can create a brand
new application from scratch it should
be great know you can use all the real
green technologies but in the other hand
you need to have empathy not only with
the code but with the whole history
dairy have all validations that that
code which not simple to read but
already had all the experience
so this is not a possibility a big bang
is not a possibility and what it can do
mark restraints few things we just
realized that you shouldn't have in any
important this mobile website all the
things should be the same codebase you
need to duplicate logic now doesn't make
any sense
like before it doesn't make two but it
was something that that company couldn't
see and locus architectures some ideas
some approaches should be something
component based like because right now
if we talk about front-end if we talk
about web applications it's pretty much
one of the good things that came to
right should be worth web friendly now
we have different browsers we have html5
API we have all the things I can use to
improve the usability they use a journey
from starting application until do what
they want to do and last but not least
it should migrate page by page but what
that means how can you just migrate one
page in the home on a leaf let's talk
about the monolith few years ago we just
heard about microservice it's a cool
architecture pattern so you can use it's
pretty pretty pretty heavily used and we
start with one question can I use micro
services as pwe application using react
or angular or vgs or any other framework
library we create frameworks and
libraries javascript every single minute
and yes we can
why firstly first of all let's talk
about architecture some i really a
really top layer when we talk about
micro services and those things micro
frameworks and micro bundles we are talk
about a micro way
the first goal is how is it is to
upgrade your application they start with
these ideas and the polenta together in
the car and now micro services like if
you have a bundle in you don't need to
care about a lot of things you have a
micro bundle and if you have a framework
they need to care about a specific
boundary you can you can use a micro
framework and so on and so forth
so long time ago angularjs just called
this as micro whatever and VW and micro
fronting okay so it's a micro service so
a front-end quick quiz what is a micro
fronting
is that a new tooling is that a new
framework like Zen a new Chrome
extension it's a technique so every time
someone talk about you like to use these
you can you should use this primer or to
use that you need to use this tooling
it's not totally related we talk about
approaches we'll talk about abductor
things and about architectural patterns
who here have you heard about strangle
pattern okay few people the interest
point of strangle partner is one of the
foundations of Microsoft's but people
usually don't talk too much about it but
what is a strangle partner at the end of
the day and how can these will be useful
for application let's give a small
example let's say that we have a
monolith application which this is
tagged to and you have a brand new stack
with only one page that we want to
migrate you need our vex arrest proxy so
you say when you let's think about the
rest proxy like when you go to a shop
market and they ask you hey Jonah pay by
by card you have different cues depend
of your gangster this guy that we call
reverse proxy just say okay you're going
to the new page so go to that side oh no
it's not that page it's not the page
emigrate
go to the old one and you can't start to
say okay let me just check 10% of the
new page it works fine
no eros it's working so far so good
twenty percent thirty percent and
carefully date for the thanks you can
use some matrix so the game starts will
be cool and hot so called problems now
we will talk about the texture thing
okay we understand how the broad and
concept among about micro front-end but
about code because we are talking about
the mono live application right so we
need to clean the kitchen before start
cook
first of all online design teams and
your developer teams to they should work
together and they have a lot of approach
talk about front-end right now one of
old code but really really useful is
atomic design by Brad Frost concept is
quite it's quite interesting like you
have atoms molecules start to be
granular until you become with a page
and but it was a long time ago that was
created now you have a lot of other
options so keep open like like we have
here at the bottom we are talking about
material design which pretty much same
idea outline everything all the teams
should be thinking together we have the
same goal and things interesting about
those two approaches at the end they
have the same goal this same idea so the
page one component is a composition of
components page two you can use or not
one of those components and it starts to
be things they start to be plug and play
and everything's a component like if you
go back here with talk about pages and
other protectress parts pretty much
component page one is a component and
all the UI components are creating our
kupuna still so Y components it's all
scope so you really have well-defined
boundaries about that idea okay I'm
doing a search box I don't need to know
about the whole world I just need to
know how to do a search and sometimes
that doesn't I just
even need to know like if you have a
really component totally the corporate
you don't even know any to know that we
have to cop something in some way and
should work and everything component is
kind of plug and play which is great
that was the first idea of the component
and that was the idea right beautiful
other things we talked about teams
distributed teams so when you do a small
component it doesn't matter if a small
component which has been used in only
one page or 30 pages please think about
empathy all the teens shouldn't prove
that that code should evolve that code
it is one idea create demo page in this
case it's being used storybook which is
a pretty cool library then you can you
can integrate if all the best frameworks
that we have right now and in the other
side you have Auto validation so you can
read easily prologue in play you can
create scenarios create some fixtures
okay you have this component and when
this component app receives a specific
property or when this property changed
what should happen you have all the
things together so easy it's easy to
read it me someone who don't know how to
code know what that cop that component
thus and on think that now is
really really up a string and it's
interesting that we have this discussion
right now because years ago we didn't
have it's about zero config part forms I
would say you can have bundles with the
your config you can have a setup with 0
config and so on but a long time ago we
didn't have this discussion so we didn't
have a lot of packages open source
packages so in some scenarios you just
can't use one of those zero configs
because of a lot of reasons internal
reasons and some business reasons or
even some rules based on the country in
those and others think and boilerplates
as a solution I will explain a little
bit more about it like why zero config
first of all opinions everyone here has
a really and great opinion about all
those steps bundle tests publish linked
we have a lot of tool is for linked
right now reporter and so on and if you
look at github right now it's pretty
impressive because when we start the
discussions you can find a lot of other
packages talking about zero
configuration such as great react app or
angular CLI ember CLI and this is great
for us because there's a lot of opinions
that we can integrate or extend however
as I said before in some scenarios you
cannot just use one of this okay let's
think about a good way to integrate you
have a tooling for example can be you
just use a yeoman generator just for a
small piece as we said before we are
working with components so we can create
a small piece and can create as a
standard in your team's and photos for
those if you have to improve or like
your boilerplate just upgraded and have
to upgrade the components who are using
this boilerplate
you can use this package called update
yeoman generator
it's pretty fun it just is solid in that
case is globally go to your component
folder and around the common and when
you read this comment it will be updated
magic that's what we like don't repeat
yourself and other thing that you can
have some benefits using this
architecture is you have a lot of firing
validations let's think about it like
first of all when you doing a bundle
when you do a deployment you had to burn
create a build bundle file for your
vendors or your page one you're paid to
sometimes we just put up there together
we talk about application long years ago
and now you can have different
approaches like now have different pages
you can create specific files for the
page one page two page three and when
you have in validations instead of
having validations for the specific
vendor you can have for the specific
file when we talk about validations USA
is a different files and you fire your
browser need to download anymore again
if you don't know more about it Sam did
a really really good talk and at chrome
dev summit last year about the future
the future of loading or web which
pretty interesting talk about this and
other points and how the web platform is
evolving to help all of us so we have a
checklist from China Kentucky right now
is great so we have volved the
application and we are happy with this
and its component based as we saw a lot
of applications the market is using a
component based application its web
friendly so every single developer who
is using that has the whole knowledge
and can use all the power of the web
platform
it's mind-blowing like we'll talk about
one thing that we had a real really
application that we had ten years ago
and now we let's talk a brand new
architecture it was validated we had all
the steps it's a production and metrics
but metrics pretty much everywhere after
you just deployed the first page you
think okay the first page done let's
keep the flow let's create some metrics
to validate and those much kusa can be a
mix of combinations can be a usual
conversion can be errors errors that you
have in that page you can create your
what makes sense for your application
there is one just one example screenshot
of a platform called New Relic so you
can just go there and do some searched
and create your your visualization for
that data and start to see hey this just
increased a little bit probably we're
having memory leak we can work on that
or okay it was it they use the
conversion just increased that's really
good let's start work at that new relic
is just example you can use a lot of
them for example Google tag manager and
adopted manager and all of them all
those steps are related to one thing
release early release often when you
have only one page you don't need to do
a deployment for the whole application
what that means things can have full
ownership of that thing at that code
that that behavior usually they should
have since since the beginning but
sometimes I thought something happened
in the mirror of the process and they
just lost this truck and release early
you have something you can easily
validate ship the production or ship and
other environments before do some
validations business
validation or even front-end validations
performance validations and so on
and now we have our amazing happen the
Division two is mobile-friendly so it's
totally web platform friendly and this
so nice and about SEO google now loves
this application if you see their last
edition it was great
91 of 100 pretty cool
everyone is happy the users happy the
developer team is happy the business
team is happy and how should be now
another point next steps right
we always think and ok we did that it's
a cycle make it make it work make it
better and we need to think about it
like now we have a micro service but
things like zero downtime what zero
downtime is what happens if your server
just goes down what's happened for the
user just see your page or the person
just don't see anything how can you work
with that so you can use some tools for
this one example is you create a service
function and store your HTML in some
place just example or you create our
engine X and store some cash so at least
for the user when it goes it access that
page it can see something and you can
make sure that at least specific or
features are available so in case like
your application if your page just goes
down for 10 minutes for the user
it's transparent the person didn't
notice that
and more about code if you wanna see a
real case just a proof of concept so you
can have first your monolith application
and after you can check page by page my
grade a if you wanna see those things
and play around this is a github repo
quick that I created so just download it
and start to play around it's required
talker but it's really straightforward
you just need to install it and run a
comment easy how should be yeah that's
it
I hope you guys enjoy as much as I enjoy
it and thanks so much
[Applause]